[Music]
hi
everybody this is garrick jones and um
thank you for joining us
today i'm here to talk to you about um
the process of my writing this book the
curious advantage
and about curiosity and what we learned
about how to transform our lives through
curiosity
um amazing process i'll also talk about
um why we wrote this book and
and and what we found about curiosity
when we did it
um i'm an author and an academic amongst
other things
and a musician and we've been
very involved with curiosity and the
ideas of curiosity
and we created a podcast series called
curious advantage and
part of doing the podcast was to meet as
many interesting people as possible and
to
uh you know get to know them and find
out their perspectives
on curiosity what makes them curious and
us being curious about them and we did a
very wide ranging
uh research we sort of did neuroscience
and we looked at it from anthropological
and behavioral
and history because we wanted to
look at curiosity from the perspectives
of the individual what does it mean to
be curious as an individual
also from the perspective of the
organization because we all form
ourselves into organizations
in these days in these days and
also socially because society
is is really um how we're
all framed and the thing about curiosity
that we discovered
so many things was that fundamentally
the most successful
countries in the world um in history the
most successful epochs
you could say we're fundamentally
curious and um
we looked at people and societies like
the republic of venice
and its thousand year history and how
curiosity was built into the structures
of that
society um we looked at the chinese and
the mongol
and and we looked at the ming dynasties
there we
we looked at syria and we looked at
syria and then
you know today we came up today we
looked at what britain has been doing
and with the royal society of arts and
how it structuralized curiosity to kind
of
help us beat the continent if you want
in the um in the in the victoria and the
industrial age
so this is these are not new new ideas
and then from the
perspective of the individual we looked
at curiosity
um from what does it mean for me what's
happening with neuroscience
what's happening in my brain when i'm
being curious what's happening
as i learn and how does curiosity link
with learning
and i think the fundamental question we
wanted to ask was
um how is curiosity valid
and and viable in the digital age
mainly because of of the following
reason well before i get into that
um i want to encourage everybody to ask
me questions as i go through
uh marcus and the producers will be
sending me the questions and i'll try
and answer them and weave them through
rather than
waiting um at the end so i want to
encourage us to have some kind of
discussion and help me to focus on what
i'm talking about
so the interesting thing about curiosity
but
um how it impacts us at the
individual level is we discovered that
neuroscientifically we all know about
dopamine we all know about the hormones
that get released
we all know about the hippocampus and
how that is related to
the fight and flights effects
that we encounter in any new situation
whether it's entering a new environment
or entering a new context
entering new knowledge we always are
slightly anxious and uneasy
until we start to gain confidence and
then we start to
lay down neural pathways that um through
our curiosity
create new knowledge in the brain all
reinforced by hormones all reinforced by
neurotransmitters
and then of course link linking to
behavior
i think um the the thing i should start
with is
is is what is
our definition of curiosity and
i would say that as a result of this
research and the result of this
book which we published
on the 1st of july and which is
available
all over digitally as well as in hard
copy and which we
worked finely on during the whole
coronavirus
lock down um the thing we define
curiosity as
is a having an attitude of wonder
but having a spirit of adventure
and those two things are go hand in hand
i think my fundamental the thing i
learned the most about curiosity was
that it's not only just about
wondering what if and how and where and
why but
it was fundamentally um connected to
behavior fundamentally connected to
going out there and doing things and
putting yourself in situations
that make you uncomfortable and learning
to deal with that level of income
being uncomfortable and going there
because
that's where we learn the most the
interesting thing about
curiosity in the digital age is that we
have an infinite
um you know amount of information
not necessarily knowledge available to
us and
how do you make sense of that how do you
weave your way through the labyrinth
of uh the internet
and all this data that's available and
the key thing for us as we discovered
with curiosity
is that being curious needs to be
linked to how you are
curious it comes back from um
it's fundamentally linked to behavior it
comes back right to the you know the
meanings of the word
curious come from uh there's the french
of course
curiosity but when you go back to the
greek
it relates to words that link to the
gadfly
that um irritates the cow in the field
for example you know the cow is always
being irritated and it's moving and
shifting because gab flies continuously
irritating it
but it's also linked to notions of of
cycles or easterners and curiosity
is linked to secular ideas and the idea
is that you come back and you do things
over and over again and curiosity is
fundamentally linked
to making and doing and we think
another one of the bigger has was that
if you're curious
you're actually not just wondering
something you
going forward and you are trying
something and you are learning by doing
and you are getting involved and you're
putting yourself at risk in some way
to kind of learn more i'll talk about
that a little bit more
as we go on the digital has
informed everything that we've done in
this book
i wrote it with two other authors simon
brown and paul ashcroft
and we came to this book because we've
been doing a lot of work
on knowledge and culture and
lots of projects on how do we enable
organizations and new ways of working
using
you know digital age and
we kept on coming back to the cultural
tropes if you like of being in
inquisitive having inquiry but then also
documenting and also learning by doing
and making
and testing and iterating and sort of
designing and so on
design thinking is came up a lot too and
this idea
always got synthesized into curiosity
and then we thought well let's
take all our great conversations and all
our research and start just
fundamentally putting it into a book and
the way we worked
we were in three different places
around the world we set up
an evernote an evernote
notebook which we shared and we started
to dump all our research into that
from all over the place because as i
said we were looking at a kind of
multi-disciplinary
idea of what curiosity could be
and after we'd gone through that phase
we realized we needed to start
clustering the data and once we thought
about clustering data we started to
understand
um concepts from ai and coding
and started to use those kinds of
algorithms to cluster our data and look
at
what was emerging in those and what came
out of that
exercise were kind of
seven major groups of thinking around
curiosity and we gave them names
and we discovered that five of the seven
uh had words that began with the letter
c
which was surprising uh and
two of them uh were sort of more general
and so the three of us played a game and
said well
could we come up with uh all of them
with the letter c
and surprise surprise we could and out
of that was born
our seven seas model and of course
when we came up with the seven seas
model we
realized that there was a metaphor and a
metaphoric connection with
um our idea of exploration and being
curious
and and so we had a metaphor about seven
disease
what we don't claim that we have a model
of curiosity that is
uh universal and fixed
we don't claim to have figured out
curiosity what we
claim is that if you are going to be
curious there are probably seven
things you should pay attention to and
those seven things
are context community
curation creativity
and construction and criticality
and confidence those are our seven c's
context
community curating creativity
construction
criticality and confidence and they
all relate it's a fuzzy system they all
relate you can use it but i'll talk
about each in turn
and also talk about the podcast to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or
visit iai.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas